good evening everybody welcome to
tonight's meeting of the East area
planning committee my name is Danny
Kendall I'll be chairing tonight's
meeting in accordance with the rules and
procedures set out in the front page of
your agendas tonight before we get
started can I ask members of the public
please make sure your phone to turn to
silent and also make you aware of the
fact that the meetings being videoed and
it is being webcast on this the council
website tonight as well I'll be
available to watch at your leisure
should you choose to wish choose to
watch it sorry at some point in the
future if you introduction some people
at the top on my far right is an banks
committee services there Mason Nash
legal services here at Stratford
District on my left Richard Gardiner
Planning Manager then we've got our
scarlet and a daily Wilson who have both
planners here at Stratford district and
we'll be presenting various applications
for us tonight right if we move to item
1 on the agenda then apologies for
absence please apologies from consumers
Mills and tongue sir or Donnell for whom
councillor Cargill is very kindly
substituting councillor Donald will
speakers Ward member thank you Thank You
councillor cargill for stepping in right
declarations of interest please
yes counselor bones I think I'm not sure
its declaration of interest thank you
any other declarations perfect all right
let's get back to the topic shall we
right ok so minutes of the meeting held
on the 15th of November your contempt I
sign those off later
true and accurate record thank you I can
do that at the end right which I want to
move or change slightly the agenda if
that's okay
owing to sort of recent information so
if the committee are okay with me
altering it's like I want to move item
six up to the front so we can deal with
that start with then we'll move through
as
numerically ordered if that's okay you
okay with that lovely so in that case
we'll start with item six this is found
on page 31 of your agendas tonight this
application reference 17 / 0 0
one seven eight slash s106 Amos the
Harbury cement works bishop searching
sermons for a variation of the section
106 agreement presenting officer ellis
cose but perhaps Richard you'd like to
give us a bit of background on this it
said okay thank you mr. chairman as
members will have noted the crux of this
case is the viability of the scheme and
the impact on the affordable housing
provision earlier this afternoon we
received an update from the ward member
raising several questions about the
assumptions in the viability statement
and the assumptions on the land value
officers aren't in a position to update
you on that because we haven't had the
opportunity for expert advice and
because of that officers recommendation
verbally is now that the application be
deferred to allow further time for
professional advice to be taken in
response to those questions thank you
Richard so my feeling is that so that we
don't go rushing into something that
we're not completely understanding of
and more members raised some very good
points I think it'd be wise for us to
defer that tonight perhaps the proposal
is deferred based on that reason do I
have a seconder get like God kill his
seconding is it thank you unless anybody
wants to ask any questions nobody should
have been doing this in confidential I
don't think we should know because the
documents aren't in the public domain I
don't play so that's okay so for that
reason it doesn't but we are where we
are so if you're all contempt all those
in favor of deferral please show are you
sorry council bonds are you I think
that's unanimous is one two three six
chairman so that for the so are you
sorry counselor are you favorite
deferral
ray you might keep your mic on okay
that's fine so we've got an abstention
here so it's fine okay
so therefore the committee can resolve
to defer this application to another
committee date in the new year a
circular is resolved to defer
application reference 17 slash is zero
zero one seven eight slash s106 a and
take off my list now as well
apologies twenty please come along for
that for that alone tonight I think it's
a good idea that we tackle it with all
the information right
okey dokey so back to the normal order
then item 4 is next and this is
application reference 17 / 0 1 8 - 2 /
ful this is tree house farm what could
road full ready Eddington and is for the
conversion of a garage to provide two
residential flats for rural farm water
workers and the presenting officer is
Daley Wilson Thank You chair ok so to
see it - showing the location of the
farm a long walk coat road is to the
northeast of full ready
there are no specific constraints but it
is located in open countryside this is a
plan so in the location of the the
garage on the farm itself didn't see the
proposals will be located to the south
of the main farm complex
okay now this is a photo of the wedding
showing the application property the
integral carriage is to the left and I
supposed to be converted and these are
the proposed elevations the main change
has been the addition of a window to the
side elevation or the west elevation as
they've done the plan and also to the
North elevation addition of a door and a
window because the picture of the rear
elevation and this is where two parking
spaces are indicated as being located
this is a picture showing the property's
proximity to the main farm complex a
garage wall is located on the right and
finally this is a picture of the main
farmhouse which is located to the north
east of the main farm complex we have
some some updates on the update sheet
first the references in the office of
support to gallery house should in fact
read gallery galley house and also we
received a patient financial information
from the agent on Monday our local
authorities a cultural consultant was we
consulted on this fellow firstly the
officers recommendation is for refusal
the air cultural consultants we
consulted on new year different
information received and indicated that
the farm is likely to be financially
sustainable however they remain of the
pension that made of the opinion
functionally it cannot be met can be met
by existing on-site accommodation with
this is of the opinion of offices at was
far maybe financially sustainable a
functioning lead has not been
established for two additional dwellings
thank you thank you daily right okay
with rates through our speakers if not
the parish or objectors registered so it
go to mr. Reece water please
to welcome mr. Walker so if you'd mind
pressing the button in the middle stay
around that decision the microphone that
should be fine you've got three minute
three minutes if you'd remain seated for
any questions at the end
all right over to you okay
only to walk upright of tree house
father full rein in a fourth-generation
dairy farmer trails farms purchased in
2013 over 200 acres and the capacity to
milk hundred and fifty cows we currently
employ three members of staff two
full-time and more recently employed
members staff due to increased stop
numbers is an apprentice for Morton
moral College the volume of work has
increased in the head of cattle
increases I expect to offer this
Prentice a full-time position such that
small dairy farm business not only has a
good management but it's also and these
have the ability to attract good quality
employees and ensure sufficient running
of the business the two full-time
employees required to live on-site to
cover their roles which starts at 4:30
a.m. and finishes at 6:00 p.m. twice
nightly checks are required at 8:30 to
10:00 p.m. these working hours are
shared between the two full-time members
of staff and myself the majority of the
tasks carried on the farm require two
people still times farming is high-risk
and long work and is discouraged for
obvious reasons the full-time members of
staff currently live in static caravans
on the farm this is far from ideal if I
wish to attract and retain staff I
recently lost one member of staff due to
inappropriate accommodation the
accommodation is something that I must
address
jails farmers to houses the main house
which are living with myself my wife of
my young son and golly house which was
not previously agreed with the previous
owner which was half built and we
completed in 2004 with rectifying a few
funds that were incorrect that we
corrected Galla house is a modern luxury
four-bedroom house it has a two-level
double garage attached galley house is
not suitable for my members of staff
they are single lads 23 and 20 years old
the house is far too large for them and
too expensive and on their basic salary
is a rural farm employees it be
unacceptable for my employees to try to
live together in this house after work
you know 12 to 14 hour day
and also the personal circumstances
could change if they have partners the
well-being is my priority for more
suitable accommodation is required we're
proposing to use the double level garage
already constructed to convert into two
flats both one-bedroom flats with open
living space
these flats will be much more
appropriate and affordable for my
members of staff to allow them to have
their own space at the end of a long day
I'm aware that the conversion of this
will devalue the property of Galerie
house and aware that spending the money
converting these flats is not want to
give me any monetary return however it
is more important for me to retain my
members of staff and invest the time and
training and trusting their work in my
business I'd like to react to it this is
not a new agricultural dwelling but this
is utilised something it's already built
and making it usable for the purposes
that it was actually built allowing this
means that the main house can be
retained and used by my herdsmen or herd
manager in the next two to three years
or even hopefully for my own son is
sensible enough he'll be follow me in my
footsteps ten seconds taken into account
all aspects of the business the most
difficult 1x5 recruiting staff and
maintaining them there is always a
difficult job with long hours I hope
that you allow me to be able to offer
tree house farm is a successful 100%
viable business in the years to come and
hopefully the fifth generation will
continue in this success thank you
excellent stuff right any questions
counselor Perry thank you good evening
it mentions in the report or the
suggestion is by the the various reports
that only two full-time members of staff
are required to manage your animal stock
etc can you just give a bit more
information as to why the needs to be
why you need an additional two I didn't
quite grasp myself as the manager I have
two full-time members of staff and I
currently have an apprentice which we've
taken on fairly recently when we first
arrived at tree house farm it could
carry about 150 cows in which time we've
now invested quite substantially in tree
house extending building to put an extra
cubicles and we now have 200
40 cows on that farm that's required for
me to get another member of staff which
came along and that took me up to two
members of staff at that point we were
actually the replacements for them cows
were actually being bought and brought
into the farm it's not ideal due to
disease circumstances and all the rest
of it what we wanted to do is to rear
our Anyang stock which we started this
year so this year there's actually
another 50 cattle on the farm taking me
up to about nearly 300 head of stock
next year there'll be another 70 young
stock as they come through again so
that'll tapped me up to nearly 400 head
of stock come back so so really the the
whole purpose is to allow expansion yes
the farm so it's not just about what
your current headcount of cows ease yes
it's to allow the farm to expand yes
absolutely thank you thank you God can't
slow barns next we didn't mention in
your speech lots of members yeah I think
the difficulty that I've found we've had
this flood recently got married and he
was given the opportunity to move into
calli house which he just said I can't
possibly afford is too much for him to
be able to do on his own his wages that
often come in dairy farming and it was
either a static caravan which yes a
static caravan or I have what I consider
to be a modern luxury house and he
didn't be I have nothing in between it's
very difficult I'd like to offer him
something in between that and that's
what I'm trying to hear my counts of
Cargill
thank you
first it's nice to hear the farming
community be able to expand and develop
that's nice applaud abour and first of
all who I think I'm picking up in gummy
house you would rent that to your staff
is that correct yes and that's why
you're saying that the costs are too
high
yes yes okay currently where do they
start live now static caravans look it's
on various site on two opposite sides I
do try to keep them apart possible like
as I said cuz the long days he's nice to
have their own space I do try to look
and what do you envisage for the use of
galley house thing going forward like
they're currently the farm I've got two
young lads as this farm expands I think
another 2 to 3 years I would expect to
take on a herdsman now herdsmen
generally earn a lot more preferably
somewhere between forty to forty five
thousand pounds a year my lads are
nowhere near that but as the farm
expands I will be able to sustain
herdsmen and that herdsmen generally
comes with a family and a wife and
that's why galley house the men part I
would like to retain in the enix
position that it is at the moment
councillor fielding I'm going back onto
the accommodation and only are the the
flats you're proposing are they above
the the garages or all the garages out
the back Gary's like a split-level so
you've two floors what we're planning on
is a bottom flat on the top flap so one
above the other yes and there has the
same front door then yes well if there
are no further questions thank you very
much your time thank you right we now go
to our ward member counts O'Donnell
welcome good right you also you have
five minutes you remain seated you know
the routine over to you thank mr.
chairman good evening committee as Rhys
Walker's mentioned he's a
fourth-generation farmer keen to
continue to build his farm up for the
next generation of walkers it's worth
noting that milk animates at seventeen
point eight percent of agricultural
output and has a market value of 4.6
billion pounds so it's a very important
part of our rural economy and also of
note is that the average Dairy Herd
number according to a House of Commons
briefing paper on dairy statistics is
136 so Rhys Walker's herd is well in
excess of that miss four exciting that
we have an expanding rural dairy
business within within this district and
we support this expanding rural business
there has been no representation by the
parish council to me opposing it
but his County Council is a sec him has
done a site visit and spoken with me at
length about supporting Rhys
now if you've done a site visit you'll
know that gali house is an attractive
for bed house set in open countryside
like I said that some people try and
abuse the act I root to add value to a
property but Rhys is not doing this he's
actually doing the opposite by
converting these garages it will lower
the value of gali house proposed is to
convert an unused garage so it's
actually the conversion of an asset
which is already built and the seems to
have been this seen to have been ignored
Rhys is asking for two small units of
accommodation which are more akin to
affordable housing for rural workers
that we know increasing the footprint of
the building no increase in population
as he seeks to house two workers
currently caravans on the site in to
more suitable flats and it's just an
example of affordable housing for rural
workers i question if it has an impact
upon local service footage restraints or
built-up area boundary as in the
officer's report the rent for a four-bed
house such as Gary house according to
your move is anything between 1600 and
1800 pounds per pound a month which if
you're a young rural worker on about
20,000 pounds after tax about 18 you're
going to struggle to meet your son you
know 50% it would have to go on rent to
reach his knowledge there's been no site
visit carried out by the council's
agriculture adviser and I question what
weight can be attributed to the advice
regarding appropriate workforce now
which I think Rita's answered well
himself this evening and accommodation
affordability and it does seem pretty
unreasonable to expect the lads having
worked in 18-hour days sometimes to live
in an intense version of farming's
answer to Big Brother all in the one
house and with girlfriends and wives
they can't really be expected to sharing
definitely it's refreshing to hear of an
agricultural employer looking to improve
the accommodation of his workers reduce
employee turnover support a career path
and provide purpose-built affordable
accommodation and as he mentioned he
sadly already lost a member of his team
the council's agricultural consultant
did not do a site visit either to
discuss financial viability and the find
that the farm is a hundred percent
financially sustainable the business
coped well with a fall in milk prices
which have now increased substantially
and they're 30 percent higher now than
they were 12 months ago I've been privy
to budget and financial information
which I know the council's legal adviser
also made available to members of the
calve committee - and with the current
Cowell numbers it's essential to have at
least three people on the farm as Reese
explained it's worth bearing in mind
this is a job that's 18 hours a day 365
days of the year so requires shifts and
with the expanding business he'll
require significant labor resource
expansion I believe the cyclic ation is
in keeping the cs9 and cs5 as ensures a
good standard of space the immunity for
occupiers and will maintain the existing
build form I would argue that it is
sustainable as a sports cs1 we
sustainability are stated in CS 15
sustainable communities are diverse and
there is no standard template to fit
them the challenge is recognizing the
specific issues affecting the various
distinctive components of our district
the principal sustainability relates to
a wide range of factors environmental
economic and social and this application
takes all three boxes it is also in
keeping with a s10 it is necessary to
help maintain the vitality this farming
community which is a key player in my
wor or an economy it doesn't impact upon
neighbors and will not increase traffic
on our rural roads provide a dwelling
that forms part of a conversion of the
building in open countryside which is
ancillary to a business I would ask the
committee to please grant this
application and help this farmer and his
workers to have honest the next phase of
their exciting rural business
development thank you thank you
council any questions for the ward
member gets the crumb quickly went
through a lot of points there one of the
point you mentioned was affordable home
for rural workers I just wondered would
that be under affordable homes and also
would there be an agricultural tie on
these flats proposed facts as well but
that's probably a question for
application later but just things you
mentioned it I just wondered if he knew
his own when I mention football homes it
was with this recommendation in the
report that the farm workers could live
in this property when you look at the
price of the rent for a property like
that that would be requesting that they
were paying over 50% of their salary
which is unaffordable so they need more
affordable housing in comparison to
their salary and there on probably about
18,000 post-tax counselor fielding
oh you're well there are other farms in
your ward where there is a shortage of
accommodation for labor not this been
brought directly to my attention
there is one no it's all part of the
farm your settlement I don't agree it's
isolated but the whole farm is an
isolated country slice it's not isolated
from the farm it's all part of a
settlement so you walk from the main
barn area it's just a couple of minutes
walk around to this this some farm
if there are no further questions
counsel Brian oh sorry
just a simple question penny yes you
referred to 18-hour days when the farmer
had said 12 to 14 hours I wonder where
you get that information from John's
Clark says I concur with rhesus figures
that's me miss reading there are no
other questions for the ward member
councillor O'Donnell thank you very much
right okay shall we go at them two
points of clarification and he won't any
questions cancer brain cancer Cargill no
there's a couple of things been
mentioned that the garage is not in use
so I assume you did a site visit second
question is we've been referred to two
mobile caravans on the site did you see
those thank you in respect to the the
first question the garage I didn't turn
to go to the garage but there is parking
to the front my understanding is that
those in terms of parking serving in the
galley that is to the front of the
property not we're going to make garage
I wanna be able to comment on whether
it's actually a second the second
question was where the mobile caravans
did you see the mobile calendar and are
they being used the mobile caravans has
mentioned in the officers reports our
subject area and enforcement
investigation as to whether they are
lawful or not
yes I can we so you're quicker just to
fight clarify your question so you're
asking where they are the map you're not
so in terms of there is a column on this
map but I believe there is a here's the
caravan just where the pointer is there
and I believe there's one just where the
pointer is there's a second is kalsekar
Gil next to apologize I'm not used to
this okay do follow her channel two
questions please if I may the first is
is there any element of this gift to be
considered a permitted development or
have those rights been taken away for
that particular property else it will be
two separate residential units they
wouldn't be able to do that under
permitted development because there'll
be two self-contained additional
residential units so every essentially
two new dwellings and obviously won't
fit under class q either so no the
second question then is I think this
this seems to revolve around the
viability of the farm and listening to
the applicant he's talking about future
plans to expand the farm to over two
hundred and forty for example and in
ultimately employing a herdsman has that
element been taken into account the
future element been taken into account
in the viability study please in respect
of the the assessment of the application
that's been submitted take place on the
information submitted as part in this
application which is which is used as
submitted as part of this application
which I believe
on situation yes it caps a Crump
I'd only and my question is to do
Willoughby if it was agreed
could we put condition on that an
agricultural tie on those properties yes
yes we could do castle bounce looking at
the picture that we have we can see
where the two guarantees yeah it looks
to be a few feet away or yards away is
that the number of other three other
buildings there I'm sorry could you
repeat what I'm saying is if you look at
the map very close to there's the two
garages it looks to be some more
buildings is that their the plan
indicates two parking spaces it's
probably not very clear but there's two
there how bonus so she shouldn't see the
farm complex itself okay counselor
fielding mixing counselor pairing can
you go back onto the planets of the
garage and the the units above because I
couldn't quite know the next one you've
just gone past so that that shows garage
doors are the the units are above with
the door because till one flat was above
the other where of us are they situated
in relation to that drawing so to the to
thoughts are located on different levels
so there yeah I got as though and where
are they in relation to what we're
looking at
do you mean in counts of fielding do you
mean in terms of where where the
existing buildings are and you try to
orientate yourself but the garage doors
on the front there this is the bottom
picture so one above shows a door going
to units whereabouts which doesn't
actually either that building is wider
than I think it is and therefore you can
have a ground floor behind the garages
there would be one flat at ground for
floor level which is the door and onto
the garages the door would be shared so
there would be an internal staircase
that leads up to the first floor one
flat and there would be an internal door
that leads to the ground floor another
flat and that flat on ground floor would
have a window serve there another one on
the side and these doors would be
retained
thank you Jeff I just wonder if I could
have officer clarification with regard
to a s10 Section six
area strategies 6.12 countryside and
villages point e where permitted
development is allowed where a dwelling
that forms part of the conversion of the
building in open countryside where it is
ancillary to a business a tour is
necessary to ensure the efficient and
secure operation of the business as a
residential development are just like
clarification from the officer on the
basis of what we've heard this evening
that why this wouldn't that this
particular strand of the core strategy
and policy wouldn't apply to this
particular the test you've described
there in our Stern is a similar test of
the one that's anticipated by paragraph
55 of the MPP F paragraph 55 tests is
specific for agricultural uses whereas
the ASTM one you mentioned is more
general for business
is that maybe have issues with having to
have someone on site at all times the
the test that needs to be met for
paragraph 55 is one around functional
lead and in this case the presence of
two agriculturally tied dwellings within
the unit means that in officers opinion
there's no need for a further two I'm
very well aware of Paragon 55 but I just
felt that because we have an additional
policy relating to business that this
particular policy might also apply for a
growing business yes it does
and but as is a specific policy
regarding agricultural uses and what
dwellings need to serve that then it
would be most appropriate to use that
specific policy the paragraph 55 test
but in answer to your question if you
were to then apply the ASTM test you get
to the same place basically in that the
functional need is already met by the
existing dwellings in my opinion and
finally capsicum page 13 is mentioned
briefly cementing in the report I don't
and it says it's got very little white
and to temporarily lift the agricultural
tie on County House for three years it
was any reason given for that was this
was that totally separate galley house
is only occupied by someone who does not
galley house itself also has an
agricultural tie on it from when that
was granted is he's coolly believed that
person occupying a house does not comply
with that agricultural tie and as a
application into very that condition
right there are no more boats picking up
on cancer parity in policy 55 Kernan's
rare agricultural experts and I didn't
recon sorted and a sort of the same
opinion that the functional need is not
there yes they were they reckon salted
it with regards to updated financial
information resulting milk prices that
satisfied them that the financial test
was met but it still didn't override the
functional need test which remains the
reason that recommended refusal right
there are no more points clarification
should we go to the debate council bonds
and caps the fielding isolated sorry
because this is a reason for refusal one
of them it looks to me years oh it's
already there it's already next to the
farmers
I can see first reason for refusal our
solution is some him ionize them doesn't
hold up as far as I'm concerned I think
they're doing a good job promote the
business we will be coming out of Europe
and we may have a chance to make some
money on milk which we are we are
exporting cheese to America now though
we shouldn't be I fully support this and
the ward member and if you would want to
put and agriculture tight obviously that
would be appropriate I don't think
there's any need for a timescale on it
myself personally because this is a need
but I should be I will be quite happy to
propose approval well I'll take your
proposal of approval but we'll come back
to it granting relation say if that's
okay council fielding I'll second what
councillor burns has said the other
thing that I do know in the area because
of my ward is next door is that there is
a grave shortage of accommodation for
farm workers and I know one farm needs
six workers so what we do need to
provide accommodation for people look
coming into them into the industry
apprentices etc and this looks like an
ideal situation but cats are Cargill
next
thank you I hope to be honest and say
when I first saw this I had my doubts
and concerns about it I looked through
the report from the office and I thought
there is a balance report and I think he
came to a reasonable judgment based upon
what and what was presented to him we do
have the viability argument put forward
by what Karen English thank you very
much indeed and obviously we have to
listen to the experts advice on that
however on the other side of the coin we
do have a situation where we have a an
expanding rural business cynic we we as
a council support and say I think where
we are as a cow's barn said moving into
a different paradigm in the couple years
time where we do need to support our
businesses especially as regards
provision of food locally grown as well
which I very keen on as well the
sustainability arguments an interesting
one because obviously this is an
unsustainable location if you take it as
a dwelling for example however because
these are working on-site that our
argument doesn't Falls and therefore I
won't I can't accept the viability
argument on this one it's a tough world
farming I do know that and so I I
applaud them kampachi putting effort
into it the apprenticeship side of
things we should support that as well
because this is something that we're
looking at nationally as well as locally
on balance I'm inclined to support this
application for the reasons I've stated
and I do feel that as council Perry said
it does fit in with a s10 or beard with
a slightly different interpretation so I
will be supporting this application
Thank You councillor to accounts of
Harry next Thank You chair I'd like to
agree with what councillor Cargill has
said but I'm just trying to wrestle with
trying to find robust finding reasons to
be able to support it so
I'm looking for other help from other
counselors that we can come up with a
robust solution that we can go against
the officers recommendation that would
stand up because I do think an
application of this merits its support
but we do have to be mindful of all the
policies in place and make sure that we
have a robust response to be able to
support it so I'll just sit on sit on
the fence and hopefully some of my other
further colleagues might be able to come
up with some good reasons to be able to
support it in planning terms yes
counselor Crump I think this is
application but I think it's slightly
premature we've been told that there
might be a harassment in a few years
time which is good because it means the
the farm is expanding even more we've
been told that they want to temporarily
lift the agricultural Tori on Kelly
house because there's somebody living
there who hasn't got an agricultural
side to the farm so a little bit uneasy
that's my problem with this we've also
got Kernan's who we employ at Acastus
agricultural consultants and our our
experts so again we should we take into
account what the I say as well so as it
stands we came back in a fuse in a
little while with the herdsman been in
place and with the staff that proposed
to be there including the apprentice I
would say yes there is a need and would
fully support it then but I think we're
a bit premature in my opinion however if
I'm in minority and council a committee
resolves to agree this I would ask that
there was definitely an agricultural tie
put on the properties
counselor brain cancer Crump's thoughts
on this one
it was the tire on the farm a switch is
not tied at the moment it's rented out
privately plus we have to take note of
Kernan's they are at experts that's what
would be better than before so I echo
what counts with crumply saying yes
council bonds this gem is very difficult
to get labour in agriculture without
having a property you haven't got a hope
of help and that means the livestock
lose is that because you lose stuff far
as I'm concerned this is in a
sustainable non open situation because
the people are at work and I'm fully
support what I put said in the
respective proposing the application I
think you should go to vote but that's
your thank you can't argue thank you and
what's to appreciate I'm not an expert
on these things I'm looking to a s-10
section K and L and M possibly end it
can't relocate business
it's not gonna be humbly let's that
spread of like this I think it should be
set specifically for this for
agricultural only conversion by building
for business purposes subjective
location well yeah it has been in
existence in 110 years I'm making an
assumption on that one
redevelopment at a similar scale of an
existing building but it's an existing
building possibly ok little 10 years on
that particular one but anyway I'm a
live counselor Perry is of a mind on
that one
right well I think we should move this
all along I had my thoughts which is
that I agree totally with what you've
said councilor Cargill and I think yeah
thank you doing leg work on core
strategy reading over there for me so
yeah I think unless anybody else wants
to speak and debate should we go to a
boat on this is that all right I mean
are you satisfied with those adequate
reasons the reasons that I picked up
from the discussion I'll go through them
in the order that have noted them that
it's not an isolated location the term
isolated here doesn't mean that it's not
close to anything any buildings it means
it's isolated from recognized
sustainable locations the nearest one I
think we've made up the point to be gold
there is sustainable location to this be
netting to they'll be my comment on that
point there was a point made about a
grave need for agricultural workers in
the area it's important when we're
looking at functional need to
distinguish between what is essential
and what is desirable and in this case
Kernan's have come back and said yes
there's an essential need to have to
work is on-site at all times but no more
so that's just something to bear in mind
which is why the officers are
recommending what they are and the other
point I got down was the fact it's an
expanding rural business
s10 does talk about that at Kay
conversion of the building for business
purposes
yeah it's Kay wasn't it yep obviously it
is I of is 10 that took that is that the
appropriate policy for agricultural
workers dwellings that would be my
interpretation of that that that's the
one
Bates this kind of application but
equally there are elements of it that
support residential uses for farms so in
my opinion they're not strong reasons
but they are nonetheless reasons we have
reasons I just wonder is there any merit
in also also adding or making reference
to e in a estern as well because it does
talk about it the conversion of the
building yep that would weigh in favor
of it yeah I think you know that these
are these are policies in our call
strategy their points in our book called
strategy that would wave to me that
would weigh far more in favorite than
let's say this is an application to to
new build Wellings and all the resources
that would take it's a benefit that this
can utilize existence nature so yes
catsup brain sorry this is to go through
chairman I just want to make sure that
they are tied to farmworkers and I don't
if it's appropriate but the removal of
the two caravans as well separate
enforcement action was going on it's a
it's a point you're making understand it
but it's not part of this application
yes I'll go back to councillor Barnes
you're happy to the agricultural tie to
be placed on this not on these two new
dwellings okay right so and the standard
set of conditions that would remove
permission of him in any way for this I
would have thought in the open
countryside officers have got a list of
conditions would you want me to just run
through the head headlines we stand a
three-year commencement condition there
would be a standard approved plans
condition there would be an occupational
restriction limiting it to a person
living near both of them to a person
solely or mainly working or less working
in the locality in agriculture or in
forestry or widowed avoid area of such a
person and fourth condition we would
recommend is the removal of the static
caravans within three months of the
first occupation of
development hereby permitted the static
caravans has already been dealt with
those separately am i right yes yes it
is subject to that but obviously the
reason presumably you're granting this
permission is because it's provide an
accommodation for the people who are
occupying those static caravans which
make the removal of their current
accommodation reasonable condition
alright thank you
right we've heard all the conditions
everything's been laid out all content
so all those in favor of granting could
you please show five channel those gates
abstentions to China thank you therefore
the committee resolves to grant
application reference 17 / 0 1 8 2 2 /
ful and we can go to item 5 the vehicle
the second smooth round
okay so next item is I defy Vince on
page 19 this is application reference 17
slash is zero two seven eight four slash
ful in his West ways little Alfred road
chantin and this is for the demolition
of existing single-story rear extension
construction of a new single-story rear
extension and two point five storey new
stairwell external alterations sorry
internal alterations and refurbishment
presenting office Casa Thank You
chairman the application site is located
in the village of Cherrington the site
hasn't lined in red on the plan
comprises an end of terrorist to a
mastery dwelling it is located in the
conservation area and the Cotswolds our
a OMB this slide shows the existing and
proposed front and rear elevations of
west waves in the context of the joined
neighbor the LEAs house so just to
confirm this is the application dwelling
here and this is the adjoined
neighboring property here planning
commission is sought for the provision
of new windows the front elevations of
dwelling demolition of an existing
single-story rear projection and its
replacement with a single-story
extension and the erection of a two and
a half story rear extension this slide
shows the existing and proposed side
elevations of the dwelling the
replacement single-story real extension
would cover approximately the same
footprint as the existing extension
whilst the proposed two and a half story
addition would project 1.8 meters from
the rear elevation of the dwelling this
photo shows west ways in the context of
terrace the existing dwelling is
constructed of Cotswold stone with a
slate roof and this elevation shows the
rear elevation of the dwelling since the
agenda went to print the parish council
has confirmed the renewal of ASAP
objection chairman the recommendation is
to approve the application subject
conditions as detailed within the
committee report thank you
Thank You Alice right so we have no
registered speakers for this and no ward
member as you say just confirm
everyone's route withdrawn their
objections does anybody have any
questions
cancer brain move the recommendation
chairman Saturday do I have a second it
has a Crump just beat you to it
everyone's happy without all those in
favor of granting
here on this chairmanship perfect right
now that protects us to application
seven okay this is on page 41 of your
agenda tonight in this application
reference 17 slash is zero to nine zero
3 / ful is six butchers close bishops
edgington and it's for a single story
side extension pretending the officer
which governor Richard thank you yes
as you say mr. chairman it's for a
single story side extension on a
residential property located in Bishop's
Hitchins and shown there on the OS plan
moving in a little closer this is the
property here you'll note that the
garden is located to the north of the
property with its frontage being facing
onto this turning head here the actual
proposed itself is a single-story side
extension this is the northern
elevations and that's what's seen from
the garden and that's effectively the
rear of the property members will note
that there's an existing two-story
extension there the proposal before you
tonight is to do this lean-to
single-story extension in that position
there and then on plan form that that
appears as this extension here with the
two skylights members will note from the
report its modest dimensions its 2.25
meters wide and 4.6 meters long and that
is the view from the east so that the
property's garden is in this area here
and there's the extension with the two
skylights I mentioned
that's the front of the property there
from the turning head I mentioned and
that's the view from the street with the
garden final slide it would appear in
that area there the recommendation is
approval thank you Richard
no one's objected and close confirm the
reason this is here it's because the
application by member of the staff
that's correct yes no one's registered
speak I will go to the ward member
should he wish to speak on this okay
thank you
right any questions just move the
recommendation again if everyone else
content I've got a proposal councillor
Cargill seconds all those in favor of
granting please show miss chairman
committee therefore resolves to grant 17
/ 0 2 9 0 3 / fu L think that is it for
the night nice one this year Merry
Christmas everybody that we have a good
honor
thank you very much meeting is is the
chairman gonna buy a drink for everybody
no no he's not the vice chairman could
yeah yeah